bonjour merci d'être avec nous jean
vincent abry c'est sur rt france alors
pourquoi les etats-unis se montre plus
ferme avec la chine sur cette question
aujourd'hui
alors les états unis auraient une
position assez ferme
l'europe aussi avait essayé d'avoir une
position assez fermé ce qui reste au
niveau des déclarations et à l'heure
actuelle la chine a été très clairement
condamné c'est ces revendications sont
rejetés sur le plan international quand
ça vient d'être appelé par un jugement
du tribunal de la haye donc à l'heure
actuelle la chine est dans la légalité
internationale et aux lilas vue d'un
traité le traité de la loi de la mer qui
a signé il ya quarante ans de ça et
qu'elle ne respecte pas non seulement on
a sûrement une propriété mais en plus en
construisant des installations
militaires artificielle sur les récifs
rhin pourquoi des états unis semblent
s'intéresser à cette zone là alors ils
états unis sont toujours intéressés à
ces zones là il ya eu il ya eu des
incidents déjà il ya longtemps
à l'heure actuelle c'est la chine qui
fait de plus en plus de ne pas timide à
sion et le forçage sur cette région et
il faut quand même pas oublier qu'à 40%
du trafic mondial de marchandises qui
passent par là qu'à pays comme le japon
est totalement tributaire d'une liberté
de passage dans cette zone et que la
chine veut fabriquer un espace où elle
aurait toute souveraineté alors racines
états unis manifestement les conflits ne
manquent pas entre les deux les copies
demande pas parce que la chine a
largement souffert comme de ce qui vient
de se passer avec quelques 8 19 la chine
a aussi très clairement des problèmes de
gouvernance
même si ça se voit pas beaucoup il ya
quand même là des contestations contre
le pouvoir le cetim pays et ses troupes
et une tour ont reçu les son peuple
derrière lui et profitant aussi la
faiblesse un petit peu du monde en ce
moment et qu'elle est en train de
prendre des positions extrêmement forte
on est ado chine du sud n'est pas
seulement mer de chine du sud on l'a vu
aussi les provocations avaient aussi
dans les clubs par exemple à propos de
temps alors on parlait tout talent de
cet incident particulier
états unis qui estiment que c'est
illégal un jugement du tribunal de las
et aussi qui a jugé que c'était illégal
manifestement la chine qu'on voit quand
même ces zones là quelles peuvent être
les sanctions les sanctions contre la
chine peuvent être assez nombreuses
il ya déjà un mouvement de
relocalisation qui fait très très mal à
la chine a toujours avec cette épidémie
qui a fait découvrir un certain nombre
de pays que être tributaire de la chine
pour toutes sortes de choses hein pas
seulement les masses que ça va beaucoup
plus loin de ça ça pose ça pose des
problèmes à long terme donc simplement
arrêter de arrêter d'importer de chine
bloquait hong kong que la chine où là
aussi la chine ne respecte pas les
accords qu'elle à qui elle a signé pour
la rétrocession en 1997
tout ça ce sont des mesures qui peuvent
être prises qui sont surtout les mesures
économiques et contre la chine de gueule
contre lesquelles la chine ne peut pas
grand chose et dans ce conflit il l'a
particulièrement à ce que la semaine des
soutiens or la chine n'a pas de soutien
de poids
elle a quelques soutiens moraux de pays
qu'elle a entre guillemets à acheter il
ya en particulier des pays africains
c'est en train de s'évanouir un petit
peu parce que les gens s'aperçoivent que
y sont tributaires de la dette vis-à-vis
de la chine
et puis il ya quelque chose d'assez
intéressant qui était un peu soulignée
par les médias c'est que la séan des
pays de la zone dont les pays d'asie du
sud est sont en train de reprendre de
l'unité une position a donc pour but
unique vis-à-vis de la chine est
beaucoup moins laxiste
la chine a essayé de casser cette unité
de la guyane elle y réussit de moins en
moins dix ans semble-t-il jean vincent
brisset merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de recherche à l'iris et
spécialiste de la chine mars